1.6 million that's the number of people
killed by fungal infections worldwide in
a single year
in 2021 at least 7 000 of those deaths
were in the U.S that's more than 15
times as many as in 1969. we're not
speeding towards the Last of Us fungal
apocalypse
but Health experts are worried about the
growing number of severe fungal
infections the kind that infect the
blood and attack the lungs in the brain
let's go over three main reasons why
fungi are becoming more of a threat and
why it could get even worse
climate change may be having an impact
on fungal Evolution this map from 2017
shows the states that reported cases of
candida Oris and often deadly fungus
fast forward a few years not only has
candida Aura spread Beyond a handful of
States but as you can see the case count
has also skyrocketed the spread to more
places is also happening with other
severe fungal infections like
histoplasmosis and valley fever their
range has really exploded over the last
like 50 years or so fungi whether it's
once you eat like these or the ones that
make you sick when your breather spores
in they like temperatures that are warm
but not too hot so as the planet warms
places that were too cold before are
becoming more fungi friendly they may
also be adapting to be more tolerant of
high heat and that includes the human
body possibly because they've adapted to
warmer temperatures it seems like
they've become better at infecting us
some recent evidence for that comes from
this study that Dominique told me about
in a lab scientists grew hundreds of
generations of a fungus called
cryptocode focused in your performance
some were grown at 98.6 degrees
Fahrenheit others at 86 degrees it
seemed that heat and hotter temperatures
was really triggering them to mutate
more the fungi were adapting scientists
have been documented this kind of heat
driven evolution in the wild yet but
that may be because this area of
research is just so new for most of
human existence we've coexisted
peacefully with fungi it seems like they
might help us digest food maybe even
fight disease fungi all around us they
help connect our forests they break down
our dead things like they're just so
critical to life it's only recently that
they've become more worrisome pathogens
ironically one reason for this shift is
modern medicine better treatments for a
range of diseases has made it possible
for people to live longer even when
their immune systems aren't working
optimally infectious fungi are
particularly dangerous for people with
compromised immune systems like patients
who are going through cancer treatment
have advanced HIV infection or taking
high doses of steroids by some estimates
almost three percent of the U.S
population is immunocompromised and this
population is expected to grow adding to
the problem is that we don't have a lot
of options for treating severe fungal
infections
it's hard to develop treatments that
kill fungi without also being toxic to
humans even at low doses that's because
fungal cells are similar to human ones
the fungi that are currently causing
disease will have developed resistance
to a lot of these known antifungals this
new study showed there were three times
as many resistant candida Oris
infections in 2021 as in each of the
previous two years the pipeline for new
drugs is also limited because of a lack
of investment but that's starting to
change so I think there has been more
interest from pharmaceutical companies
from researchers to really look at this
as a potential area of of r d but it's
still kind of burgeoning and there are
drugs and clinical trials from several
companies it's important to remember
that even though the thread from fungi
is growing dying from a fungal infection
is still pretty Rick this study
estimated that in 2019 7.7 million
people died globally from infections
caused by bacteria like E coli and staph
aureus that's almost five times as many
as have died because of a fungus and on
a lighter note if you're still scared
that a fungus that looks like this can
turn you and your friends into zombies
there is no indication that that's going
to happen at least not any time in the
next few million years you know fungi
have to really evolve to be able to do
that that's a relief